is this blindness oh the white rook can
just step forward one square and capture
a black pawn
and he has and magnus look at him oh my
words just hallucination he forgot this
pawn was up for grabs could it be a
mouse lip could he have intended to play
the queen because i think look at
shakarya trying to look around the
computer to see what's going on i don't
think it's a mouse slick because he he
as soon as he only when shaq took the
pawn did he react
he's done two of these incredible
blunders he he missed the bishop move
the other day and he's missed the rook
move today
early in the event yeah wow i mean this
is this is now game match everything
yeah white has a rook and a pawn for
black's bishop now but the white rook is
free that's the clear thing the white
rook has scope over the whole board it's
game over as you say simon
look what he's done to the bishop as
well dark square bishop well
it's not that's king it's not a great
piece because it's blocked in by its own
pawns
oh no like you say